le procès de maurice papon devrait bien
avoir lieu le 6 octobre prochain c'est
en tout cas ce qu'a affirmé hier soir le
ministère de la justice un report avait
été évoquée en raison des difficultés
techniques et financières liées à
l'accueil de quelque 600 personnes au
tribunal de bordeaux
maurice papon l'ancien secrétaire
général de la préfecture la gironde ou à
répondre de crimes contre l'humanité
dominique verdeilhan le procès de
maurice papon les victimes l'attend
depuis 15 ans elle ne souhaite pas
patienter deux mois de plus c'est le 6
octobre que devait s'ouvrir à bordeaux
les audiences devant juger
l'ex-secrétaire général de la gironde
comme pour le procès de klaus barbie à
lyon une salle préfabriquée devait être
aménagée dans la salle des pas perdus
prévue pour au moins deux mois ce procès
doit accueillir plus de 200 témoins et
victimes et plus de 70 journalistes un
budget de 8 millions de francs étaient
prévus mais les devis s'élève à plus de
15 millions hier soir à bordeaux on
envisageait de reporter le procès à
décembre ou janvier 98 impensable
s'exclament les parties civiles il n'est
pas sûr que les témoins qui ont été
sollicités à l'art actuel est peut-être
une chance de vie il faut tout est
limité à l'heure actuelle et tout est
réduit
une décision opportune tout sera fait
pour maintenir la date du 6 octobre
s'engage ce soir le ministère de la
justice mais tout porte à croire que le
procès de maurice papon se tiendra en
fait dans l'actuelle cour d'assises une
salle dans un premier temps écarté en
raison de sa petitesse une installation
vidéo permettrait une retransmission à
l'extérieur ce soir les conseils des
victimes et de maurice papon sont au
moins d'accord sur un point ils exigent
que les audiences se déroulent dans un
climat digne d'un procès pour crimes
contre l'humanité